michael wittmann héros de légende du
troisième reich
[Musique]
en ce matin du 13 juin 1944 au début de
la bataille de normandie
le ss auberge comme fureur wittmann et
l'équipage de son char tigre se tenait
prêt à entrer en action
il était sur le point de prendre part à
l'un des plus célèbres affrontements de
chars de l'histoire militaire wittmann
avait laissé sa compagnie pour
reconnaître le terrain il y aura tout un
bataillon de blindés britannique qui
faisaient une halte sur une route des
alentours
[Musique]
nullement impressionnés wittmann dirigea
son blindé droit sur la colonne d'iran
en roulant
le tigre avait l'avantagé de la surprise
il détruisit rapidement 12 half track
trois chars légers et six chars de
combat
ce fut l'un des exemples frappants de la
maîtrise de l'engin et de ses
possibilités démontré en 1944 par le
lieutenant wittmann à bord de son tigre
transmet ici l'exemple type d'un chef de
char accompli avec en plus la capacité
instantanée de cerner la situation
tactique
je pense que le fait qu'il fut capable
avec un seul char de détruire toute une
colonne blindée britannique est
probablement un record dans l'histoire
du combat de chars wittmann qui t'a
tranquillement le lieu du carnage pour
faire son rapport réarmer et rassembler
des renforts deux heures plus tard il
retournait au combat cette fois il
détruisit encore douze chars de combat
quatre chars lourds et 14 de
chenillettes brain tout cela en une
seule journée de guerre pour celui qui
fut l'un des plus brillants chef de char
de toute l'histoire
wittmann fut très probablement l'un des
plus brillants jeunes chef de char de
toute la seconde guerre mondiale
non seulement il peut se targuer d'un
tableau de chasse sans précédent m avec
138 chars et 130 de canons antichars
aussi d'avoir été le récipiendaire des
plus hautes distinctions militaires du
régime nazi comme par exemple la croix
de chevalier de la croix de fer avec
feuilles de chêne et glaive l'équivalent
allemand de la victoria cross
il fut un meneur extrêmement brillant et
un chef extrêmement compétentes une
source d'inspiration pour éteindre
je pense que cela amène un autre constat
aussi important à savoir la valeur
ajoutée que michael wittmann apporte à
la propagande nazisme il ne s'agissait
pas seulement de ses exploits sur le
champ de bataille il faut prendre en
compte son influence et son exemplarité
auprès des autres combattants mais aussi
des ouvriers dans les usines qui
fabriquait le tigre avec lequel wittmann
remporta la plupart de ses victoires
donc hormis ce que l'on peut penser de
ses opinions politiques et du fait qu'il
était de toute évidence un nazi dévoués
en termes purement militaire tant au
niveau tactique que psychologique
son impact fut immense auprès des
allemands que les alliés nickel wittmann
naquit dans le petit village de vogele
talent dans le haut palatinat le 22
avril 1914
il était le premier fils d'un fermier
johan wickman et de sa femme ursula par
1934 âgé de 21 ans wittmann rejoint
l'armée allemande signant un engagement
de deux ans au début du régime nazi le
service militaire obligatoire n'avait
pas encore été réintroduit
bettman était donc volontaire au moment
où ils s'engagent à freising au sein du
19è régiment d'infanterie la reichswehr
n'était qu'une petite armée de
l'entre-deux-guerres
elle n'était composée que de volontaires
ce qui lui conférait une grande force
wittmann correspondait parfaitement à
ces standards après un an de service
il fut promu caporal le 1er novembre
1935 1936 fut l'année de gloire du parti
nazi en allemagne les premiers succès
économique des national-socialiste
d'hitler impressionnèrent le jeune
wittmann dans le monde fermé de l'armée
la ferveur de ses collègues nazi lui
firent elle aussi grande impression
beaucoup de ses camarades prévoyait de
rejoindre la waffen ss nouvellement
formé évitement décide à lui aussi de
rejoindre les rangs de la branche
militaire du parti nazi après son propre
service militaire le 1er décembre 1936 8
man postulat chez les ss et fut acceptée
dans ce qui allait devenir l'une des
organisations militaires les plus connus
de l'histoire
les waffen ss constituaient les forces
armées régulières le fer de lance
idéologique de la cause nationale
socialiste composé au moins dans ses
premiers temps de jeune homme
extrêmement bien préparé physiquement
raisin but d'idéologie de supériorité
raciale
c'est un mais finit par compter en 1945
près d'un million d'hommes et
fournissaient environ 40 division de
combat aux forces armées allemandes les
waffen ss unités militaires d'élite de
l'allemagne nazie et est issu des
sections de protection et d'intervention
les schutzstaffel ss en abrégé c'était
des combattants d'élite aux tactiques et
aux tenues très innovante
ils furent par exemple l'une des
premières troupes à utiliser des tenues
camouflées
de nombreux militaires allemands
exceptionnels comme le maréchal erwin
rommel ont constamment essayé de
minimiser l'entousiasme qu'ils
éprouvaient pour hitler et son idéal
ce n'est pas le cas de mickaël wittmann
en ce qui le concerne il n'y eut pas de
conversion rédemptrice ni de changement
tardif d'allégeance c'était un homme
simple et le pouvoir d'attraction du
parti nazi l'emmena à cette allégeance
sans faille malheureusement il ne dévia
jamais de cette voie néfastes wittmann
reçu le matricule 31 1623 et se révéla
un national socialiste modèle sur son
temps libre il participait aux sports au
recrutement et prenez part aux
manifestations de masse et au meeting de
l'époque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
contrastant avec le monde fébrile des
meetings politiques
la première affectation de wittmann chez
les ss fut moins excitante garde aux
grands dépôts de munitions de la
wehrmacht
wittmann ne tarda pas à s'ennuyer il
voulait être au coeur de cette nouvelle
force en action il se présenta donc pour
rejoindre la ss life stand d'achter la
gare de personnel d'hitler
c'était déjà l'unité la plus
prestigieuse et la plus élitiste du
troisième reich
[Musique]
hitler constituait la garde prétorienne
dit la forme et en 1933 comme garde
personnelle du führer elle devint
l'avant-guerre de militaires du national
socialisme
en 1943 elle finit par devenir une
pudeur division de la waffen ss à part
entière comptant environ vingt mille
hommes à la fois en tant que division
été préalablement tant que régime ans
elle fut engagée sur les fronts les plus
importants de la seconde guerre mondiale
quand que fer de lance blindés des
offensives allemandes et en tant que
brigade de réaction rapide renvoyé sur
les secteurs du front qui cédait sous
les coups de l'ombre c'était réellement
une unité d'élite ou en neige
grâce à son parcours militaire sans
faute
wittmann remplissait les critères de
sélection très strictes et fut acceptée
il entama sa formation avec sa nouvelle
unité le 5 avril 1937 à l'école
principale des cadets de berlin
lichtervelde wittmann fut affecté à la
dix septième compagnie qui était une
section d'automitrailleuses de
reconnaissance
c'était une formation d'élite les hommes
de cette compagnie de reconnaissance
blindés recevaient un entraînement très
poussé qui en faisaient des experts ses
capacités allen maintenir en bonne
condition mais pour le moment cette
nouvelle expertise reste est inutilisé
hitler atteignait ses objectifs grâce au
bluff et à des coups de dés audacieux
[Musique]
en octobre 1938 wittmann participe à
l'invasion des sudètes l'accueil des
populations il enthousiasme dont il fut
le témoin achevèrent de l'impressionner
plus encore peut-être que la ferveur qui
émanait des meetings du parti nazi
[Applaudissements]
il reçut à cette occasion la première de
ces nombreuses médailles elle
commémorait la réunification de
l'autriche et des sudètes avec le reich
allemand
à partir de cette date les médailles et
les décorations allaient se multiplier
dans la carrière de mythes man
les premières étapes du grand plan d'
hitler avaient été exécutés sans
effusion de sang
mais alors que les tensions montaient
les projets fous dit claire ne pouvait
mener qu'à une spirale de chaos la
conquête de la pologne inaugurera le
début de la seconde guerre mondiale
le régiment motorisé de la ligue
standaard combattit durement en pologne
dès le premier jour de la campagne le
1er septembre 1939
ce jour là la section de reconnaissance
blindés fut engagé très vite les
wittmann reçu son baptême du feu
la campagne de pologne fut brève 30
jours seulement mais cette première
expérience avait réveillé son goût pour
l'action
dans l'année qui suivit wittmann et son
auto mitrailleuses furent à nouveau
engagé au combat dans la courte campagne
qui allait faire tomber la france
[Musique]
widemann avec d'autres sous-officiers et
hommes du rang fut transférée à une
borne ou la batterie de canons
automoteurs était en train d'être formés
la ses camarades et lui échangèrent
l'uniforme noir des panzers contre les
tenues grises de canonnier d'assaut deux
ans a laissé couler avant qu il ne revêt
à nouveau l'uniforme noir de panzer
ce fut le début de l'association de
wittmann avec les véhicules de combat
blindés qui allait le mener à la
célébrité en allemagne et l'ua loire la
haine de ses adversaires il y avait tant
à apprendre les canons d'assaut étaient
armés de tout cours de 75 mm très
différent des faibles canons de 20 mm
qui armait les automitrailleuses
wittmann fit rapidement la démonstration
de capacité remarquable avec cette arme
une fois terminée la période de
formation
la batterie de canon d'assaut fut envoyé
regard nizon en france après la courte
période d'activité intense qui avait
caractérisé la campagne éclair de france
les mois d'occupation semblèrent l'on
m'a wittmann qui n'avait de cesse de
retourner au combat
il allait devoir attendre jusqu'au 6
avril 1941 avant de voir son voeu exaucé
la campagne des balkans commencer les
forces allemandes avancer vers la grèce
à travers la yougoslavie en plus des
forces grecques
il devait affronter les troupes
britanniques et celles du commonwealth
le canon d'assaut de bittman fut engagée
dans les durs combats du col de cléty
qui ne tombât qu'après une farouche
résistance puis la ligue standaard dû se
frayer un chemin à travers le col de
clis barre puis à corinthe et à olympie
contre une résistance très durs de
l'armée grecque
la bataille de graisse pris fin le 30
avril 1941 après une halte en thessalie
en mai la nike standaard fut envoyé en
radio slave i à kandy dit prêt de michao
ou ils attendirent la prochaine phase de
la guerre
l'invasion de la russie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'opération barbarossa fut lancée le 22
juin 1941
mais la langue standerton ne fut pas
engagé au début
nos guerres en union soviétique commence
à un mois plus tard en juillet 1941
ce fut comme un second baptême du feu
pour mickaël wittmann qui affronte à
l'assaut de 18 chars russes lors du
premier jour de combats
il n'avait rien connu de tel en pologne
ni en bresse mais wittmann était
naturellement combatif il réussit à
détruire six chars ennemis d'affilée les
autres fuir le champ de bataille en
catastrophe ce fut le premier succès
flagrant de wittmann qui montera là les
premiers signes de son talent
incontestable
en tant que commandant de véhicules
blindés le 12 juillet 1941 en
reconnaissance de son grand fait d'armes
le premier jour de son déploiement en
russie dit man fut décoré de la croix de
fer de seconde classe
mais il ne disposera pas de temps pour
fêter cet événement il fallait repartir
[Musique]
leucan en cours de 75 mm de l'auto motor
des premières années de guerre était une
arme moins puissante que le 76 mm du thé
34 russe mais en dépit de son
infériorité wittmann se révéla un maître
dans l'utilisation des blindés au combat
la guerre en russie était très exigeante
avec les équipages d'automoteurs
fréquemment wittmann et son équipage
étaient seuls séparée du reste de la
batterie
dans cet environnement hostile
il se révéla être un chasseur solitaire
efficace malgré tout il reste très
populaire auprès de ses camarades
le tireur de wittmann de l'époque aux
touches alt le décrivait comme un homme
modeste
michael était un sous-officier calme
talentueux et amicale soucieux des
objectifs à atteindre
il connaissait son blindé il connaissait
aussi son adversaire il se positionnait
magnifiquement bien
et chaque fois faisaient une tentative
pour le déborder ou l'éliminer ou au
moins lui mettre la pression
les forces blindées allemandes étaient
dispersés sur un front de 3200 km
wittmann n'était heureusement bon
guerrier solitaire car les canons
dassault était rarement utilisé en masse
comme les ordres le requérait les durs
combats de 1940 est un développeur ses
capacités les commandants d'unités et
est toujours heureux d'avoir un canon
d'assaut affectés à leur secteur en
particulier lorsqu'il s'agissait de
celui de michael wiedemann l'avancent
allemande le long de la mer noire
commença dans les premières semaines
d'août 1941 wittmann combattit près de
ça ces liens enovia bug du 10 au 17 août
et prix personnes le 19
[Musique]
dans les combats pour la prise du port
de kherson un événement surprenant se
produisit lorsque les canons d'assaut
commandé par wittmann et beck engagèrent
un navire ennemi puis un sous marin
le navire fut coulé mais les effets du
tir sur le sous marin ne sont pas
connues
wittmann avait détruit dix chars et demi
à ce stade de sa carrière
mais sa chance allait tourner lorsque
son véhicule fut touché par un
projectile qui ne perd fera pas le
blindage
mais le blessa au visage et au dos
[Musique]
les équipages de chars font face à un
grand nombre de danger différent ou
combat stars les plus évidents sont ceux
causés par leurs homologues ennemis char
canon d'assaut chasseurs de chars et
canons automoteurs de plus les nuits à
beaucoup de canons anti char tracté ou
non qui du fait de leur petite taille se
cache facilement michael lipman
reconnaissait qu'il fallait plus de
chance pour détruire un canon antichar
qu'un char et demi natation les
équipages de chars devait aussi
affronter l'infanterie ennemis équipés
d'armes antichar à courte portée les
obstacles antichar les tranchées les
champs de mines etc
enfin il reste elle est simple problème
de confort en opération les chars
avaient tendance à être remplie de
toutes sortes d'équipements dont
certains étaient tranchant en terrain
difficile les équipages pouvaient être
blessés par ces équipements ce qui
n'était pas très plaisant mais leur plus
grande peur était le feu qui en espace
confiné ne laisser que quelques secondes
pour évacuer leurs véhicules endommagés
ça
5 août après la prise de kherson
wittmann se repose après de bobrie net
en récompense de ses exploits michael
pittmann fut décoré de la croix de fer
de première classe le 8 septembre
il était alors déjà considéré comme le
meilleur chef de pièce de sa batterie et
un membre indispensable de la ligue
stand barton
l'as vence allemands de continuer vers
l'ukraine orientale taganrog fut prise
le 17 octobre
michael whitman qui avait été blessé
trois fois en 1941 fut promu au grade de
au beurre sharks fureur c'est à dire
adjudant
[Musique]
dans l'eig stoddart avait été malmené
par les mois de combats ininterrompus et
la capacité de combat de ces unités se
situer à un niveau dangereusement bas
malgré tout les unités continuer à
pousser vers l'est
le 17 novembre la taille de rostov sur
dont fut lancée la ville ne fut prise
qu'après des combats acharnés
le 21 novembre
michael whitman fut décoré de la
médaille d'argent des blindés
la ligue standaard gagna ses positions
hivernale le long de la sambre est qu
tandis que la batterie de canon dassault
était stationné à taganrog delà les
canons d'assaut menaient des
reconnaissances à l'est et au nord les
combats de chars étaient relativement
rares ce stade du conflit car les
soviétiques n'avaient plus que quelques
équipages de chars encore opérationnel
le tableau de chasse de bethmann
s'agrandit encore avec 25 chars et 30 de
canons anti chars détruits
mais les pertes au combat n'était pas
seulement du côté russe
celle de son propre conte augmentait
régulièrement
en février 1942 la batterie affaibli fut
renforcée elle atteignit l'effectif d'un
bataillon grâce à des renforts venus
d'allemagne et le transfert d'une autre
batterie de la division ss wiking en
conséquence de cette expansion wittmann
se porta candidats au grade d'officier
début 1942 il quitta le bataillon en
juin pour participer aux cours
d'officiers à la ss juncker schuhl de
battles
[Musique]
wittmann bénéficier d'une formation
tactique qui vint s'ajouter à sa propre
expérience du combat
âgé de 28 ans wittmann servait
maintenant comme chef de peloton à la 2e
compagnie du panzer bataillons de
réserve de la ss durant cette période
loin des combats il fut promu au grade
de hunter stumm fureur sous-lieutenant
le jour de noël 1942 il reçu son ordre
de mission pour falling boston afin de
former la nouvelle compagnie de chars
lourds wittmann échanges a à nouveau
cette nuit grise d'artilleurs pour
l'uniforme noir des panzer
des rumeurs circulaient selon lesquelles
une nouvelle arme miracle allait bientôt
voir le jour
répondant aux attentes de wittmann et
ses camarades
les rumeurs vont bon train dans les
armées mais pour une fois elles étaient
fondées
les allemands allaient bientôt être
équipés de l'incroyable chars tigre
wittmann allait pourtant être déçu
chaque compagnie de tigre comptait
quelques qte panzer 3 pour la
reconnaissance et le soutien comme ils
avaient de l'expérience sur les
automitrailleuses et qu'il était
entraîné à se servir de ces engins
wittmann fut affecté un panzer 3 et non
un tigre sa déception fut grande
[Musique]
wittmann voulait son propre tigres mais
il allait devoir attendre encore
longtemps
il ne manquait jamais l'occasion
d'affirmer que son désir était le
commandement d'un charlot finalement en
mars 1943 il atteignit son but et pu se
tenir pour la première fois dans la
tourelle d'un tigre en tant que chef de
char
wittmann n'eut pas le temps de méditer
sur son nouveau statut
la situation stratégique du front russe
était désespérée et les tigres étaient
engagés directement aux combats de
gigantesques duel de chars les pires
combat à un contre un et les batailles
contre les canons antichars constituait
le travail quotidien de michael wittmann
[Musique]
son premier grand triomphe eu lieu lors
de la titanesque bataille de koursk en
termes d'échelle et d'intensité de
combat la bataille de koursk n'avait pas
de précédent dans l'histoire militaire
récente illustration parfaite de cette
bataille
l'engagement autour du village de
prokhorov caire le 12 juillet 1943 au
cours duquel mille charlie ss panzer
corman du côté allemand et de la 5ème
armée de la garde du coût des
soviétiques furent concentrée sur une
zone de seulement quelques kilomètres
carrés
je pense que c'est ce qui rend la
bataille de koursk tout à fait
le jour même où cette grande bataille
commence à wittmann détruisit oui chars
dans les combats de blindés qui
s'ensuivirent 8 man apparu comme un as
des charges sans égal il battait de
vitesse les batteries d'artillerie
repérer même les canons antichars les
mieux camoufler et neutralisaient les
chars ennemis ils étaient prudents quand
il devait l'être agressif lorsque cela
payait son instinct affûté de chasseurs
combinée à une large part de chance lui
permirent de sortir sans une égratignure
de cinq jours de combats furieux lors de
la plus grande bataille de chars de
toute l'histoire encore et encore les
chars ennemis prenait feu comme des
torches devant lui
lorsque michael wittmann éponge à son
front ruisselant est couvert de poudre
le soir du cinquième jour il savait
qu'il laissait derrière lui trente char
t34 28 canons anti chars russes et deux
batteries d'artillerie totalement
détruit
wittmann poursuivi sur sa lancée à la
fin de l'automne près de broussilov il
pénétra dans une zone de rassemblement
de chars russes prenant l'ennemi par
surprise
et lors de cette seule action détruisit
dix chars parmi la masse des blindés
soviétiques trois de plus tomber sous
les coups de son tigre plus tard dans
l'après midi
wittmann compte à chaque char vaincu
mais considéré les canons antichars
qu'ils détruisaient comme ayant deux
fois plus de valeur
il détestait ces armes camoufler qu'il
surnommait cachette de la mort il
jubilait lorsqu ils détruisaient un
canon antichar whitman déclara qu'il
avait cessé de craindre les charrs et
demi et que seuls les canons antichars
le rendait encore nerveux il les
décrivait comme tapie dans leur repaire
est nettement plus difficiles à repérer
que les chars le département de la
propagande nazie voulait exploiter les
succès de wittmann un reporter de guerre
fut envoyé pour le suivre dans son char
voici ce qu'il rapporte à lors d'une
attaque contre une grande ville
solidement protéger nous avons ouvert un
passage en détruisant rapidement
plusieurs chars et canons antichars et
bientôt nous entrâmes envies nos cibles
étaient tout à droite du chemin que nous
voulions emprunter pour traverser le
centre
soudain sur notre gauche derrière une
meule de foin nous rhdp ramin joseph
staline 1 avec son canon pointé sur nous
wittmann ordonna tourner à gauche cible
à son maître feu
et ce fut tout
cet engagement eu pour résultat la
destruction de quinze chars ennemis le
premier jeu wittmann manoeuvre est
fréquemment le tigre d'après son
expérience des canons automoteurs d'une
position statique il pouvait faire
pivoter son engin en entier plutôt que
de perdre du temps à faire tourner la
tourelle pour manoeuvrer le tigre de
cette manière il suffisait d'actionner
une chenille dans un sens et l'autre
chenille dans le sens inverse
il fallait faire très attention avec le
tigre car on risquait de le voir des
shows c'est une de ces deux énormes
chenilles pendant son pivot
les chenilles actionnée dans des
directions opposées accumulait de la
terre sous les galets de roulement ce
qui risquait de les coincer
contrairement à la plupart des équipages
de chars le tireur de wittmann bobby vol
tirer souvent sans que son chef lui
désigner une cible car comme le disait
souvent wittmann il n'y avait pas le
temps pour une conversation moby vol
prenait sa bise est très souvent en
quelques secondes qui faisait la
différence entre la vie et la mort le
tigre fut l'instrument du succès de
michael wittmann c'était un monstre
d'une grande dangerosité mais dans les
mains de hitman il atteignait son plein
potentiel d'une manière que peu d'autres
chefs de chars allemands n'ont jamais
réussi je pense qu'on peut considérer
que non seulement le tigre attrait fait
michael mythe même mais que michael
wittmann a fait le tigre l'impact
psychologique du tigre qui était déjà
considérable fut largement magnifié par
l'excellence du commandement de michael
pittmann à la tête de chartis grax et
par la propagande que les allemands
furent capables d'exploiter à partir de
ses exploits c'est donc une relation
très symbiotique ou synergique que nous
observons
le tigre était une âme extraordinaire
surtout dans les mains d'un équipage
expérimenté cette époque les allemands
avaient aussi déjà participé aux combats
de pologne de france et certains avaient
aussi servi en espagne et dans les
balkans
il disposait de soldats très motivés et
très efficace capable de se servir de
n'importe quelle arme nouvelle
il avait réservé le tigre au meilleur de
ses seuls wittmann avait évidemment fait
ses preuves durant les premières phases
de la guerre est l'opportunité pour lui
de combattre dans un tigre était
évidente
le 15 janvier 1944 les troupes blindées
de la life stand d'achter et de la
division das reich reçurent l'ordre de
progresser vers le nord ouest en
direction de l'ue au bar
cette avance blindés fut stoppé
principalement par des tirs nourris de
canons antichars et de mortiers ces deux
jours d'intenses combats
permira wittmann de détruire six chars
20 canons antichars 60 pièces
d'artillerie 32 camions et de nombreux
autres véhicules
le 16 janvier 1944 wittmann et bobby vol
reçu la croix de chevalier paul fut le
premier soldat d'un grade tel que celui
de tireurs à recevoir une décoration
aussi importante il y avait maintenant
deux récipiendaires de la croix de
chevalier dans le tigre de wittmann en
tant que membres d'équipage de bittman
le succès de vol sur pas c'est celui de
n'importe quel tireur au cours des
batailles divers de 1943 et 1944 à la
date du 13 janvier il avait détruit 80
chars et 107 canons antichars
bobby veulent jouer un rôle important
dans le succès de michael wittmann grâce
à sa réactivité et son excellente oeil
il était un maître avec le canon de 88
mm confiant dans les capacités de vol
wittmann n'étaient pas intimidés et
engageait souvent des chars ennemis en
nombre supérieur
les deux formes est une bonne équipe et
vol exécuté à la lettre les tactiques de
wittmann
alors que le pilote l'opérateur radio ou
le chargeur changeait régulièrement le
chef de char et son tireur restaient
ensemble aussi longtemps que possible
le chef du tigre était intimement liée à
son tireur et leurs actions nécessitent
à une grande coordination les autres
membres de l'équipage de wittmann post
ici pour des photos de propagande en
janvier 1944
on peut y voir werner heel gang
l'opérateur radio again suite le pilote
et des promeneurs le chargeur
en tant que tireur vol était d'une
importance capitale parce que s'il
manquait son coup le prochain tir ennemi
pouvait leur être fatal à tous
balthazar vol le tireur du tigre de
michael wittmann suivait une méthode
assez personnelle il prêt réglait ses
instruments deviser sur une distance de
800 m qui était la distance moyenne de
tir à laquelle le tigre engagé ses
cibles il corrige et ensuite pour la
cible qui se trouvait plus près ou loin
en se fiant à sa grande expérience et à
son intuition pour tirer au dessus ou en
dessous du point indiqué par les organes
devises
une façon très rapide et efficace
d'utiliser le canon
les anneaux peint sur le canon du tigre
de mythes man représente chacun dix
chars détruits
[Musique]
les tigres étaient redoutées par les
soviétiques et les chars lourds
allemands subissent est souvent
d'intenses tirs anti char durant leurs
attaques
il servait d'armes de rupture pour créer
des brèches dans les défenses ennemies
par lesquels l'infanterie allemande
pouvait ensuite progresser dans
d'innombrables attaques
il perd sert des défenses anti char et
détruisirent des positions d'artillerie
ennemis grâce à leur grande cadence de
tir
ils pouvaient surpasser n'importe quel
char sur le champ de bataille
bien que déployés en faible nombre les
tigres se montrèrent incroyablement
performante en défense qu'en attaque
sous le feu constant des canons
antichars des fusils anti chars et des
lance roquettes
les tigres ne s'en sortait pas indemme
mais leur épais blindage frontale les
rendaient difficiles à détruire
souvent les obus et demie rebondissait
simplement sur leur protection frontale
quoi qu'il en soit le tigre n'était pas
invulnérable
le rythme d'arrivée des nouveaux
exemplaires venue des usines allemandes
tournante à plein romain suivait
toujours les pertes subies
[Musique]
les incroyable exploit de wittmann sur
le champ de bataille ne passèrent pas
inaperçu il devint rapidement un héros
national le 2 février 1944 il fut
convoqué au quartier général d'hitler
michael lipman reçu la croix de
chevalier avec feuilles de chêne des
mains d'adolphe hitler en personne lors
de sa conversation avec 8 man hitler
s'aperçut qu'il lui manquait une
incisive suite à une blessure il
l'envoya chez son dentiste pour lui
faire remplacer satan le succès de
michael whitman semble être fondée sur
certaines capacités exceptionnelles il
était connu pour deviner où les
embuscades serait susceptible d'être
tendue beaucoup de soldats évoque un
sixième sens lui permettant de repérer
où les positions ennemies pouvait se
trouver tout spécialement de nuit il
était capable de pressentir où et quand
le danger pouvait se présenter avant
tout wittmann était un homme très
sérieux dans le combat et dans la guerre
en général il rejoignit les ss car il
croyait profondément à la doctrine nazie
ce qui n'était pas exceptionnel à
l'époque sa foi en cette doctrine lui
permit d'acquérir un grand sens du
devoir
lorsqu'ils revenaient du front
victorieux il participé à l'instruction
des jeunes soldats
il était très engagé dans cette tâche
sérieux mais dépourvu d'humour lui fit
exécuter des corvées pendant un mois des
soldats qui avaient ri de le voir
déséquilibré est tombé par terre lors
d'un exercice wittmann était un chef
on avait le comportement particulier il
n'admettait pas que l'on se moque d'un
supérieur
quel qu'en soit le motif
[Musique]
wittmann profita d'une brève pause pour
se marier avec hildegarde bouwmeester
encore une fois ce ne pouvait être qu'un
événement typiquement nazis après la
cérémonie de mariage un diligentée par
le maire en personne
wittmann reçu en cadeau une copie de
mein kampf un discours suivi prononcée
par le f'tour ban fureur payne qui
déclara que la philosophie de vie des
teutons avait encore du sens dans leur
propre vie
la période de calme de wittmann fut très
courte le 6 juin 1944 les alliés
débarqué en normandie
c'est là que sa réputation allait
devenir légendaire
une des chansons les conditions en
normandie ont dû être terrible pour les
tankistes allemand la supériorité de
l'aviation alliée à ce moment là les
obliger à se déplacer à couvert sous
peine d'être éliminés immédiatement si
vous regarder n'importe quelle photo
d'équipage de chars durant la campagne
de normandie
vous verrez qu'ils regardent fréquemment
le ciel pour mieux repérer les avions de
grande concentration de blindés
regrouper pour exécuter un assaut
méthode la plus efficace dans le combat
blindés auraient été attaqués très
rapidement par les avions alliés
ceux ci rendait les conditions de combat
très difficile
le matin du 13 juin 1944 wittmann était
en position près de villers bocage
lorsqu'il surpris un escadron du country
of london liés aux mânes riz les troupes
britanniques s'étaient arrêtés pour le
petit déjeuner lorsque le tigre de
wittmann apparu en un clin d'oeil les
réflexes de wittmann et de bobby vol
permirent de détruire 12 half track
trois chars légers et six chars de
combat wittmann se replier ensuite et
rejoignit trois autres tigres et un
panzer 4 à 8 heures une unité de
reconnaissance signal à borj touil
fureur wittmann une importante colonne
de blindés ennemis qui avançaient sur la
route entre villers bocage et quand big
man qui se trouvait à couvert avec son
tigre au sud de la route
aperçu le bataillon blindé britanniques
suivis par un bataillon de transport de
troupes en anglais avançons vers villers
bocage
la situation nécessitait une action
immédiate widemann ne pouvant
transmettre ses ordres à ses autres
chars qui avait décroché se lance
immédiatement vers la colonne
britannique ouvrant le feu en mouvement
cette rapide intervention ses parts à la
colonne en deux à 80 mètres de distance
wittmann détruisit quatre chars sherman
firefly positionnant son tigre contre la
colonne et la remontant à 10 ou 30
mètres en parallèle il réussit à
détruire douze chars ennemis dans un
très court laps de temps
les transports de troupe des scores
furent presque entièrement réduisent
ensemble
les chars allemands et la compagnie
d'infanterie firent près de 130
prisonniers mais wittmann parti en avant
de sa compagnie vers la ville de villers
bocage
c'est très intéressant d'observer la
façon dont il se positionnait comment
ils détruisaient cessible une par une
il était extrêmement bon tacticien que
maître absolu du combat blindés individu
est l'illustration de ce qui pouvait
être accomplis par un chef de char très
aguerris soutenu par un équipage
d'experts ben et servant un excellent
blindé à l'écotaxe
juste avant l'autel du bras d'or il
détruisit un autre char sherman et se
retrouvait alors face à plusieurs chars
ennemis à la sortie de la ville sur la
place jeanne d'arc
il fit faire demi-tour à son tigre et
remonte à la rue principale
alors qu'il passait devant le magasin de
vêtements us godefroy le tigre fut
touché par un tir de canon antichar qui
détruisit indé barbotin entraînant la
chenille mais cela ne l'empêcha pas de
détruire tous les chars ennemis à sa
portée et de décimer l'unité ennemis
wittmann lui-même raconte l'histoire je
décidé d'abandonner mon char nous prîmes
tout l'armement que nous pouvions
emporter mais je ne détruit pas le char
car je pensais que nous pourrions
revenir le chercher
nous réussîmes va rejoindre la division
à 15 km de là nous dûmes esquiver des
chars ennemis à plusieurs reprises
nous aurions pu les détruire à courte
portée mais n'avions pas d'armes
antichars avec nous nous avons donc dû
les laisser passer à contrecoeur nous
rejoignez la division est filmé notre
rapport immédiatement la contre attaque
qui en suivit détruisit l'ennemi et nous
reprîmes la ville le gros du régiment
blindé et un bataillon de fusiliers
furent anéantis
zeb dietrich son supérieur exprime à
plus tard son admiration dans son
rapport
widemann s'est frayé un chemin à pied
vers le nord sur une distance
approximative de 15 kilomètres jusqu'au
quartier général de la pause l'air
division à partir de là il retourna au
combat avec 15 points eur 4 de la panzer
l'air division est pris à nouveau la
direction de villers-bocage grâce à sa
détermination
widemann et son tigre détruisirent la
plus grande partie d'une puissante
colonie britannique agissant seul et de
sa propre initiative en faisant preuve
du plus grand courage il prévint le
premier ss panzer cops d'une menace sur
la totalité du front mais il n'y avait
plus de réserves disponibles pour le
cops en prenant un compte l'action
d'aujourd'hui wittmann a détruit un
total de 138 chars et 130 de canons
antichars avec son tigre signé dietrich
ss aubert gruppen fureur panzer général
des rvs afone ss l'engagement de
villers-bocage fut important il permis
d'empêcher les tentatives des
britanniques de contourner le gros
centre de communication de caen depuis
l'est sans dire que mickaël wittmann ou
tout autre individu aurait pu influencer
le cours de la campagne de normandie de
cette manière est un non sens il est
assez évident qu'aucun individu n'aurait
pu seul à jouer un rôle aussi
déterminant dans une campagne qui était
géré un de bien plus haut niveau en
reconnaissance pour cet incroyable fait
d'armes à savoir le plus grand nombre de
blindés détruits par un seul char en un
seul jour de combats le führer décoré de
la croix de chevalier dans l'ordre de la
croix de fer avec feuilles de chêne et
glaive le ss oberstorf fureur michael
lipman commandant d'une compagnie de
chars lourds
wittmann et et le 71e soldats des forces
armées allemandes à être ainsi honoré
hitler connaissait la valeur de wittmann
en tant que héros national et le presser
d'accepter le poste d'instructeur où il
aurait pu transmettre son savoir faire
si chèrement acquis wittmann préféra
rejoindre son bataillon au front il
sentait qu'on avait besoin de lui là bas
et son profond sens du devoir ne lui
permettait pas d'accepter un poste
tranquille huit vannes savait que la
guerre était entré dans une phase
décisive
malgré la supériorité matérielle de
l'ennemi qu'il avait observé et
affronter personnellement en normandie
videmanette est optimiste en regagnant
le front il passe à seulement un court
moment avec sa jeune femme avant de lui
dire au revoir et de partir pour la
normandie
cela devait être sa dernière affectation
le 8 août 1944
widemann livre à son dernier combat
au cours d'un engagement qui ne serait
pas resté dans l'histoire autrement son
char d'emprunt numérotée 007 fut pris
pour cible par des forces britanniques
supérieure en nombre
un tir direct fit exploser la tourelle
du char wittmann et son équipage furent
tués sur le coup le plus grand chasseur
de chars de l'histoire de la guerre
était mort michael wittmann est crédité
de 140 victoire sur des chars ennemis
dette mais il semble évident que le
nombre de 25 victoires
la villa bocage soit en réalité pas la
lumière d'éléments récent plus proche de
6 peut-être de 12
il faut ajouter les attaques d'un grand
nombre de transports de troupe au matin
qu'ils n'avaient aucune défense contre
un tigre le débat vient de la campagne
de russie
les scores étaient annoncés par de
brillants chefs de chat afin de remonter
le moral des troupes mais aussi pour la
propagande à l'arrière les allemands
étaient enclins à glorifier leur as des
blindés tout comme leur as de l'aviation
durant la campagne de russie
il se battait souvent avec du matériel
inférieur le t34 était un excellent
temps qu il la plupart des victoires
furent acquises contre des chars légers
sans aucune réponse possible
c'est donc une protection adéquate face
aux tigres et aucune chance de le
détruire
wittmann et son équipage sont enterrés
au cimetière militaire de la cambre en
normandie près du site de sa plus grande
victoire à villers-bocage une belle
demeure éternelle pour un indomptables
guerrier
[Musique]
à